[Music]
we have many people from diverse
backgrounds who are getting certified
but what we find is that especially for
individuals who are interested in
certifications it could be that they are
looking to go into a new job role were
you know just upscale in a certain area
they want to demonstrate that they are
skilled in in something specific and not
only demonstrate that to their peers but
also to potential future employers so
really I think it's about career
advancement but also it can be more I
think self-motivated where you just want
to kind of prove to yourself that you
have these skills maybe you've been
studying something for a period of time
you've been completing trainings or
practice practicing something on your
own and getting that certification is
kind of that milestone proof that you
have those skills certifications in
particular can be used by individuals to
learn new skills kind of motivate
themselves to learn new skills find a
new job move into a new area that's
interesting to them and so our goal is
to help signal to the industry or maybe
just to their teams if they're staying
you know within their same job role that
they have specific skills that they have
met this kind of standard for the
industry and for that job role so that
recognition the career advancement but
also the just intrinsic validation for
yourself that you have the skills that
you can need to do your job
you